y llegamos en directo hasta la ciudad de
madrid la capital de españa y se
encuentra en esta enviada especial a la
cumbre de la otan esther herrera este
relax saludo muy buena tarde hoy como ya
lo vimos también lo adelantábamos en los
informativos previos a este enlace con
usted pues ya es el último día de esta
cumbre recordemos un poco y hagamos un
resumen de lo que ahí se habló el día de
hoy
se hoy ha sido un día mucho menos
cargado que los días previos en que se
ha tratado sobre todo las amenazas por
ejemplo las del terrorismo en especial
las provenientes del norte de áfrica y
también en la región del sahel una zona
que preocupa especialmente a españa por
la proximidad geográfica pero también a
francia se ha hablado de cooperar más
con países por ejemplo especialmente con
mauritania pero también en la zona de
oriente medio como jordania y también e
irak para cooperar más en cuestiones de
inteligencia a todos los aliados han
insistido en que es importante poder
cooperar con todos estos países y
también vigilar todo el flanco sur sin
olvidar que ahora mismo la amenaza
directa y más importante es rusia para
la seguridad de la otan todo esto se ha
recogido en el plan de los próximos diez
años aprobado aquí en esta cumbre de
madrid esther también se ha hablado
mucho que esta cumbre de madrid ha sido
diferente ha sido histórica en muchos
aspectos pero porque qué puntos digamos
han sido que esta cumbre sea diferente a
las demás y además la mar que toda la
pauta en una década
si así es el secretario general de la
otan jens stoltenberg ha asegurado que
se trata de una cumbre transformadora
que marcará el futuro de la organización
porque cuestiones para empezar se va a
reforzar todo el flanco oriental con
300.000 fuerzas algo que no se veía
desde los tiempos de la guerra fría esto
es algo realmente histórico que muestra
una prueba de cómo ha cambiado el mundo
desde febrero desde la invasión de
ucrania por otra parte también habrá más
presencia de eeuu en la alianza su
presencia no se producía tanto tampoco
desde la guerra fría de hecho el
presente eeuu joe biden ha asegurado que
se trata de una organización de europa y
no de una finlandia ción por lo tanto
también una muestra más de cómo está
cambiando el mundo también los aliados
han mostrado su apoyo inequívoco a
ucrania con un plan financiero también
militar una muestra clara de cómo los
aliados están apoyando a ucrania a pesar
de no ser un miembro de la otan y por
último también esta aprobación de que
finlandia y suecia sean los dos próximos
miembros de la alianza pronto podría
empezar el proceso de ratificación
ampliando a más de mil kilómetros la
frontera con rusia